this unmanned flying device is spying
for science scientists at the yulish
Research Center used the little remote
sensing drone to assist their research
on plants they've been growing new types
of energy crops on their test field
the bird's-eye view provides the best
vantage point for judging which crop
will generate the most biomass for
making fuel it's an elegant surveillance
method especially when the weather plays
along it's always fun to watch it and to
see the pictures afterwards but the
really exciting thing for us is the data
we get from these images one of the
bigger research projects at Yiddish is
the future of the world's energy
supplies that includes plants that can
be turned into biofuels which crops are
best which ones grow fastest and most
uniformly these pictures from above are
fairly unusual outdoors I generally have
the familiar aspect of a normal field
but from above I get a completely
different view of the homogeneity of
this crop images taken at different
wavelengths show the scientists how
efficiently the plants photosynthesis is
working which nutrients they need and
how fast they grow the challenge is to
find a way to grow energy plants without
occupying fields that are needed to grow
food crops species like the North
American Cup plant could help put an end
to the competition between fuel and food
Nadya Madison plants with these plants
were trying to avoid that conflict
because with these plants we can go on
to marginal soils poor soils that are
not suitable for food production
here in their greenhouse the researchers
test the growth under laboratory
conditions they can check 500 plants a
day in the fully automated facility the
aim is to find varieties with the
highest yield and the greatest
resistance and breed them as energy
crops an important indicator is root
growth especially developed CT scanner
shows this clearly energy plants need
strong roots because after the harvest
they have to grow back quickly OVA sure
has built up a network of research
institutes and universities the goal is
to integrate basic research results into
agricultural practice the scientists
believe modern plant research has a huge
potential for the future and they're
optimistic about the possibility of
replacing fossil fuel with biofuel
without making more people go hungry
it's a competition against HIV in the
future there'll be a whole series of
plant species that we can use energy
crops food crops will have a great
diversity of different plants there
isn't going to be just the one plant
that can do it all but we'll have
different plans for different
applications
in that vision common grain plans would
no longer be used for energy at most the
wastes left over after harvesting food
crops could be processed into fuel even
straw can be used to produce fuel either
as an additive for gasoline or as pure
bio ethanol the scientists at yudish are
especially interested in energy crops
that grow on poor soils that way they
can ensure that valuable acreage for
food plants won't be sacrificed energy
from the field the German government
also sees a big future for the concept
and is pouring generous funding into
research in this area